what's going on Wolfgang you may have
caught my video a couple of days ago
about how the Infinity Gauntlet and
Thanos are permanently damaged if you
haven't seen the video you can check it
out in the link above but I found this
out by the commentary that was provided
by the Russo brothers who directed the
film and they themselves said that the
Infinity Gauntlet and Thanos are both
permanently damaged if you haven't had
the opportunity to hear the commentary
yet I'm giving away a few copies of
Avengers infinity war on blu-ray all you
have to do to enter is subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment
below with your favorite superhero
so the Infinity Gauntlet is damaged it
couldn't take the power of all the
Infinity stones being used at one time
at least not for something as big as the
snap but the more I think about this and
the more that I watch infinity war over
again it makes me think something
doesn't really line up here when Thanos
collects all of the Infinity stones Thor
hits him with lightning he then throws
Stormbreaker at Thanos and Thanos
combats it by using the Infinity
Gauntlet and as you can see in this
still right here he's using all of the
stones in the Infinity Gauntlet when he
tries to combat storm breaker but
Stormbreaker ends up being more powerful
than the Infinity Gauntlet Stormbreaker
overpowers the attack from the Infinity
Gauntlet and goes right into fan OSes
chest how is this possible the Infinity
Gauntlet has the power with all of the
stones in it to wipe out half of the
universe how is Stormbreaker able to
overpower it and ask yourself is the
Infinity Gauntlet really not strong
enough to handle the snap it seems to
have handled the power of all the other
stones individually just fine so it
makes me wonder if each tree somehow
sabotage the Infinity Gauntlet each tree
is a master forger I'm sure he could
have made an Infinity Gauntlet strong
enough to withstand the snap and he
forged storm breaker which seemed to
work just fine against the Infinity
Gauntlet and not to mention he's made so
many super-powerful weapons for the
Asgardians gun near Odin's spear
being one of them so I think he's fully
capable of designing a gauntlet that's
strong enough to use all of the stones
even with the snap and Eitri is a very
intelligent person he knew exactly why
Thanos wanted the Infinity Gauntlet he
knows what his mission is and yes danos
threatened his people but with the
Infinity Gauntlet thanos threatens half
of existence so while designing the
gauntlet maybe he put some sort of
failsafe in it something that if the
Infinity Gauntlet was used to the full
extent and Thanos succeeded in wiping
out half of the universe would give
whoever has left a chance to undo it and
the way you give these people a chance
is to make the Infinity Gauntlet
unusable so perhaps he didn't design it
perfectly
perhaps he designed it to where it was
strong enough to complete the snap but
not strong enough to survive the snap
yes it could possibly use one stone at a
time but it's definitely too damaged to
be able to complete another snap or
simply something that Thanos wills
because that is the power of the
Infinity stones it can do whatever
Thanos wants so I think it's too damaged
to do that Eitri has been surrounded by
a ton of magic in all the years that he
has been alive I'm sure he knows that
time travel is possible whether it be by
magic or by science technology whatever
it may be I'm sure he knows it's
possible and we know that Avengers 4 is
going to have time travel in it so to me
it makes a lot of sense that III would
design the Infinity Gauntlet to break
after Thanos performed his snap but this
is just a personal theory of mine what
do you all think do you think that this
makes sense let me know your thoughts in
the comments below and another reminder
about the giveaway I'm doing to enter
the infinity war blu-ray giveaway all
you have to do is subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment
below with your favorite superhero thank
you so much for watching woof woof
[Music]